educational entities weren't just
keeping kids out of schools they were
discovering new ways to pollute their
minds breitbart reporting that through
teacher training lectures like
cultivating anti-racists and activists
in kindergarten and decolonizing the
minds of second graders the nation's
leading accreditation association for
private schools it's called the national
association of independent schools is
instructing educators to adopt what's
called a race essentialist curriculum
for children
one of their chief instructors is a
former black panther
that notion of diversity that we really
reached out to include for instance the
dominant culture of white students and
teachers in this work i think it's
important to have representation in what
our students are studying all the way
down to pre-k
and talking about things like race
like gender
like social class for our youngest
learners i think the whole notion of
assessing with an equity lens is so
critical it's there that we begin to see
the bias surface
joining me now bob woodson founder and
ceo of the woodson center bob
we keep thinking it can't get worse but
now they're all exposing themselves your
take on this
well first of all i thanks for having me
on laura um this this whole emphasis on
race
it really is the flip side
is i think uh white progressive
narcissism
that somehow that the destiny and
and and future of black americans depend
upon what white people do or do not do
dr king really warned against that in
his letter from the birmingham jail when
he said the greatest stunning block to
black progress is not the white citizens
council or the kkk
it is the white moderate that lukewarm
acceptance from people of good will is
more difficult to tolerate than outright
rejection of people of ill will
and some of these progressives that are
teaching this poison to our children in
one sense are worse than bigots they're
worse than hardline bigots
because they are really preaching
self-annihilation
every five minutes laura
a child is shot in america
i know of a black woman who lost all
four of her children her four sons to
homicide before the age of 30.
there is a crisis in america
and and the answer to those kind of
challenges are not going to come from
teaching white people to be less racist
it is it is is narcissistic to believe
that but also harmful to the nation it's
poisonous
i don't want to hear another white
person say to me
i cannot confront this truth be bob
wilson i'm white i can't say that only
you can
that's crap
white america has to summon the courage
to stand up against these
progressive bigots
well bob we were talking about this in
relation sorry to interrupt but we were
talking about this in relation to disney
and that's kind of the more the sexual
propagandizing
and but it but it's this corporate
environment that they're foisting on
employees where it's the equity
diversity equity inclusion agenda which
on its face that sounds fine but then
when you dig into it it's not it's it's
not about tolerance this is about you
must believe you must think you
and it it just creates an intolerable
environment for free thought and free
you know free expression period and
learning
it's it's not only intolerable but it's
insulting but they're using the the
black
uh
issue about justice as as the reason
for the need for it and i'm saying that
that is just not shared by the majority
of black americans
you talked about the governor desantis
he won because a hundred thousand black
low-income black people voted for him he
only won by 32 a thousand votes because
of his position on vouchers and
education even though obama and oprah
winfrey came in to campaign for gillum
the white so black america low-income
black americans do not share this
passion for racial diversity that is
being thrust on them by black and white
elites oh i get white guilt
always comes back
bob um your perspective so needed
tonight thank you very much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else